Speaker 1: Why don't we go next
to Chris from Philly? Chris,
welcome to the program.
What is on your mind today?
Chris from Philly. Please accept my invitation,
sir. And Chris, you're currently self muted.
Hello? Yeah. Now you're on.
Speaker 3: Okay, I already have some plan of
action. But to piggyback off the one thing the one
guy said I would like to see Biden for the black
community is to hold banks feet to the fire for
the back hurting. Red lighting that they're doing.
Speaker 2: Mhm.
Speaker 1: Absolutely. I agree with that.
Speaker 3: I got customers coming and I got
to hurry up. Another thing I wanted to say was
Marjorie Taylor GREENE on the
Home Security. I mean, was named.
Speaker 1: The Homeland.
Speaker 3: Security problematic?
Yeah, it's really problematic for the
simple fact that she was sitting and
chasing down Parkland shooter survivors.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Customers coming in.
Speaker 1: Chris, what kind of work do
you do? What kind of customers are these?
Speaker 3: I'm a manager at the British
Riviera to my employees calling opportunities.
Speaker 2: I'm working on
myself. At where? Where are you?
A beer distributor.
Speaker 1: Oh, a beer. I
thought you said that Baron Steyn bears. And I was
like, What are you talking about, Chris? A beer
distributor. All right, very good. Well, Chris,
listen, I'll let you get to the customers. Okay?
Speaker 2: I hit you back with everyone.
Speaker 1: All right. Text me later.
All right. Okay, man, a lot of
crazy, crazy stuff going on today.